the next installment in the Ant-Man
series will Mark the beginning of Phase
5 of the MCU as a result it has some
very big shoes to fill here's what we
know so far about this epic of miniature
proportions
black panther wakanda forever closed out
phase four of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and now Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania will kick off phase five
however it wasn't always supposed to be
this way originally the Marvels the
Further Adventures of Carol Danvers
Kamala Khan and Monica Rambo was set to
take off on February 17 2023 while
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania would
arrive on July 28th of that same year
however the third Ant-Man movie was
further along in production so it was
decided to swap the two films now the
three quill will hit theaters on
February 17 2023 where it will compete
against other 2023 movies such as
cocaine bear knock at the cabin and
Magic Mike's Last Dance
everything's going pretty great for
Scott Lang in the aftermath of End Game
and his five years stuck in the quantum
realm he's back with his daughter Cassie
his partner hope and his mentor Hank Pym
he's pretty famous now showing up to Red
Carpet Events and getting recognized on
the streets everything seems golden
until Cassie invents a device that
results in Scott's and Company getting
sucked back into the quantum realm now
our heroes are stuck in this bizarre
microscopic world one populated by all
sorts of strange characters and scruffy
looking riffraff in addition to the
various creatures lurking about there is
also Kang the Conqueror the dimension
hopping time traveling Dominator of
Worlds Kang is reportedly stuck in the
quantum realm and according to footage
shown a d23 he needs Ant-Man to fetch
something that was stolen from him of
course if Scott helps he'll unleash
Kang's destruction upon the Multiverse
in addition to the conflict between
Ant-Man and Kang we also know the
relationship between Scott and Cassie
will be an important part of the story
the director Peyton Reed said one of the
single most intriguing things that I was
excited to do in this movie was progress
the Scott Cassie relationship Cassie is
now a young woman she has become a
scientific mind in her own right she's
been going through Hank pym's old
journals and notebooks and has really
latched onto this idea of quantum
science and Quantum technology however
that won't be the only interesting
parent-child relationship at play as
things will be strained between hope and
Janet Van Dyne having recently escaped
the quantum realm the Elder wasp is
keeping a few Secrets something hope
will find out the hard way speaking at
ccxp Evangeline Lilly explained there is
a lot that hope doesn't know and doesn't
find out about her mom until this
Journey Begins and it's a dark and
difficult thing to deal with for her
outside of the first real appearance of
Kang the Conqueror who first appeared as
he who remains in Loki the most
important development in Quantum Mania
is the appearance of stature Cassie
Lang's superhero Alter Ego she's another
piece in the Young Avengers puzzle
that's been developing since the start
of phase four with the inclusion of
characters like kid Loki Kate Bishop
America Chavez and Billy and Tommy
maximoff we can also expect to see one
of the strangest characters in all of
Marvel footage at the 2022 San Diego
Comic-Con confirmed that Modoc will be
making his Grand MCU appearance and
know what Modoc stands for mental
organism designs
in the comics the character is a
floating giant head with tiny limbs
which means that he is packing around
quite an impressive brain we're not sure
who's playing Modoc or what his role in
the story will be some fans suspect it's
Corey stalls during cross after being
trapped in the quantum realm but we
can't wait to see what Madness Modoc has
in store we're also interested in
digging deeper into the quantum realm
talking to Entertainment Weekly director
Peyton Reed said we've only scratched
the surface of the quantum realm thus
far he explained we wanted to go in a
different direction and create an Epic
movie where the bulk of it takes place
in the quantum realm for me it was
really exciting because the other two
films take place in San Francisco in
this one we were creating this
incredibly complex subatomic world
as you might expect Paul Rudd and
Evangeline Lilly are coming back to
their respective super roles Ant-Man and
the WASP they'll be joined by Hollywood
Legends Michael Douglas as Hank Pym and
Michelle Pfeiffer is Janet Van Dyne and
while Cassie Lang will play an integral
part in the film she'll be portrayed by
a new actress Emma Furman played an
older Cassie in Avengers end game but
here she'll be portrayed by Catherine
Newton a freaky and big little lies we
can also expect to see several other
Ant-Man stalwarts show up on the big
screen Randall Park will work his magic
as agent Jimmy Wu and Greg turkington is
coming back as Dale the guy who fired
Scott from Baskin Robbins Jonathan
majors of Creed 3 and Lovecraft country
will be playing the villainous Kang the
Conqueror a bad guy with major
implications for the rest of the MCU
perhaps the most interesting bit of
casting is comedy Legend Bill Murray
speaking with Entertainment Weekly
director Peyton Reed revealed Marie
plays a character from Janet van dyne's
past it's a crucial role as we know from
great stories you can put the past
behind you but the past will always find
a way to show up again Bill's character
represents that in this movie rounding
out the cast we know that William
Jackson Harper of the good place will
show up in an undisclosed role and if
you're a fan of Tim Robinson's I think
you should leave we've got some good
news Reuben rabassa the scene stealing
character actor from season one's focus
group sketch will also appear in Quantum
Mania while some Marvel series see
different creators come and go there are
also quite a few Heroes who've teamed up
with a particular filmmaker and never
looked back for example there's James
Gunn and the Guardians of the Galaxy
John Watts and Spider-Man Ryan coogler
and the wakandans and of course Peyton
Reed and Ant-Man Reed has directed both
previous installments of the Ant-Man
franchise and now he's coming back to
the quantum realm for ant-man's biggest
adventure yet speaking about the Scott
Lang franchise Reed told Entertainment
Weekly people felt like oh these are fun
little palette cleansers after a
gigantic Avengers movie for this third
one I said I don't want to be the palate
cleanser anymore I want to be the big
Avengers movie
every so often Kevin feige and the folks
at Marvel Studios will find a creative
talent and latch on hard that's what
they did with Jack Schaefer and Michael
Waldron the same seems to be true for
Jeff loveness who's been handed not one
but two massive jobs for Marvel
previously loveness was a scribe for
Rick and Morty a show known for its dark
humor multiverses and time travel with
that background and sci-fi silliness
it's no wonder he was brought on to pen
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania however
he's also been tapped to write Avengers
the Kang Dynasty which is directed by
Destin Daniel [ __ ] and will hit
theaters on May 2nd 2025. interestingly
there's a pretty obvious connection
between the two projects the villainous
warlord Kang who will appear in both
movies it seems to imply that
quantumania will be setting up some
pretty big Stakes for the rest of the
MCU
from She-Hulk smashing her way through
Court to Namor declaring war on wakanda
to a werewolf running around causing
chaos there's a lot happening in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so where
exactly does quantumania fit in well the
third installment of the Ant-Man series
picks up after the end of the infinity
Saga but it's still grappling with
everything that went down in phase three
in the previous ant installment Ant-Man
and the WASP Scott hope and Hank learned
that Janet Van Dyne was alive and
trapped in the quantum realm prompting
the ant family to visit the world
Between Worlds to pull her out after a
successful Mission it was Scott Lang's
turn to get trapped inside thanks to
Thanos getting his hands on the Infinity
Stones in Infinity war and snapping the
rest of Scott's crew out of existence
leaving him stuck in limbo haha very
funny
Hank quit screwing around you told me
yourself not to screw around after years
trapped inside Scott used his knowledge
of the quantum realm in Avengers end
game to help Earth's Mightiest Heroes
harness the power of time travel
allowing them to visit the past retrieve
the Infinity Stones and undo thanos's
murderous snap of course during his time
away Cassie Lang grew up quite a bit
meaning Scott found himself with a
teenage daughter Upon returning to the
world however the events of the Ant-Man
series aren't the only ones critical to
understanding quantumania as it turns
out the events of Loki are pretty
important as well in season one of the
Disney plus series the god of mischief
and Loki variant Sylvie plan on bringing
down the time variance Authority the
organization in charge of maintaining
the sacred timeline their Quest
eventually brings them to he who remains
a Godlike figure who ended a multiversal
war waged by his variants by coalescing
all the desperate timelines and worlds
into one unfortunately for the MCU when
an enraged Sylvie kills he who remains
she disrupts the sacred timeline and
allows for the arrival of his most
dangerous variant Kang the Conqueror
with the villain set to appear in
Quantum Mania Loki season 2 and Avengers
Kang Dynasty it seems like we have the
next Thanos on our hands one who will
make his first official appearance in
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
set to a heightened haunting version of
Goodbye Yellow Brick Road the trailer
for Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
finds Scott Lang living the good life
the x-con is now a beloved celebrity for
defeating Thanos and restoring half the
universe but when his daughter Cassie
Lang invents a device that's like a
satellite for the quantum realm
everything falls apart fast as Scott and
his family are sucked into a bizara
world full of alien-like creatures
strange plants a micro-sized society and
brand new threats Janet Van Dyne makes
it clear that there is more to this
place than one has suspected complete
with dangerous secrets and foes those
new dangers show up in the form of a
sunglasses wearing Bill Murray and cold
calculating Kang the Conqueror who wants
something from Scott
[Music]
and give you more time
if you help me the trailer is also
filled with the standard Ant-Man series
humor such as someone mistakenly
identifying Scott Lang as Spider-Man and
our boy being named Baskin Robbins
employee of the century we also see a
star wars-like collection of Rogues and
Rascals patrolling the quantum realm and
hanging out at an otherworldly bar most
importantly we also get a glimpse of
Cassie Lang in her new super suit
implying she'll be taking on her comic
book mantle of stature
foreign